[Music]
hello
welcome everyone welcome to the stanford
graduate school of business
joint and dual degree webinar we're so
happy to have you here today
we're going to be spending the next 45
minutes or so together
to hopefully answer your questions about
stanford's
joint degree and dual degree programs so
just a few
fun facts about the stanford program to
sort of ground us
today uh while we get settled and start
a little bit about
uh just learning about the school itself
uh we're going to launch a poll
because we're really curious in hearing
from you and we'd love to know when
you're thinking about applying to
business
school that can certainly help us frame
our conversation today whether you're
thinking about applying this year
or maybe a couple of years from now so
keep a look out for a poll that will be
launching soon
and while we do that i'm going to
introduce you to
the stanford graduate school of business
program so
one of the really unique elements of the
educational experience here
is that you're not only going to get a
world-class
business education through the mba
program but you also have access to all
of the leading schools across
stanford's campus so approximately 80
of our mba students will actually choose
to take at least one of their electives
somewhere else across stanford's campus
during their time here
but as many as one in five are actually
pursuing a joint or a dual degree during
their time here
and that's going to be the focus of our
conversation today
so there are a few distinctions between
what constitutes a joint degree and a
dual degree
and we're fortunate to have our joint
and dual degree advisor
jennifer on our call today so for those
of you who have any questions about some
of those details and the logistics and
the tactical elements of the degree
we'll call on jennifer to answer some of
those but we really want to spend the
time with
our students and alumni who have
actually gone through these programs and
who can speak to their personal
experiences so we've just launched the
poll here and we'd love
if you could just take a moment to let
us know when you're planning to start
your mba experience
that will be really helpful for us as we
continue our conversation today
i shared a brief uh introduction to our
program
next we're going to turn things over and
meet our panelists
i'm going to kick us off with a few
questions to get us started
but really we want to utilize the time
today to hear from you
and hear your questions so at any time
feel free to enter your questions in the
q a box and we will try to get
to as many as possible in our time
together today
for those of you who may not have
immediate questions you're just curious
we have turned on the upvoting feature
so if you see a question
in the box and you're also interested in
hearing the answer
go ahead and upvote that because the
more upvotes we see the more likely we
are to be able to get to that question
today
all right so with that
i'd love to introduce you to our alumni
panel we are so fortunate to be joined
by some students
sorry alumni now i although i knew many
of them as
students uh who have participated in a
few of our different joint and dual
study programs
so what i'd love to do to kick us off is
actually turn things over to each of you
to just introduce yourself by name a
little bit about what you were doing
before school
and the joint degree program you pursued
and then i'm gonna go
into a couple of questions to get us
started thank you for inviting me and
i'm very happy to be here my name is
juan manuel
and i am currently living in mexico city
i was
i joined the gsb in 2014 and i did
consulting before the gsb
i graduated in 2016 and i went back to
consulting for two years but with the
goal that one day i will
be part of the education world so after
two years in consulting i
came back to mexico and i am currently
the
ceo executive director of in singapore
mexico teach for mexico
and i love my job and the dual degree
really really prepared me for for the
job that i currently have
wonderful thank you so much aida how
about yourself
perfect thank you christine hi my name
is ida hempel i'm calling in from
san francisco right now and i graduated
from the gsb
in 2019 and although i guess i should
copy it but i actually finished the
eiper program which is the master's
program in environment and resources
sort of early 2020 to serve two and a
half years at stanford which was great
um both so i generation investment in
san francisco we are
um a investment manager focused on
sustainable investing i sort of
focus on our climate investments both in
growth equity and in real assets
and before gsb i was in management
consulting at the boston consulting
group
uh great to be with all of you today
thank you eda sorry for mispronouncing
your name
there uh david how about yourself you
were somebody who did a joint study with
another school so tell us a little bit
about that
yeah hey everyone david demarest calling
in from atlanta
georgia i heard one other person from
atlanta which is awesome
i actually had a non-traditional
background before gsb but you'll hear
that from a lot of gs beers
i started out after college took a few
years as a professional
triathlete and then worked in higher
education for a number of years
for yale university my alma mater and
after that decided to go back to school
and so i did the
gsb and dual degree with harvard kennedy
school
so like christine was saying earlier
doing
an mba at gsb allows you to do
other dual and joint degrees at stanford
but also
uh other places too which is pretty
incredible i thought
uh clearly because that's that's the
route i ended up choosing
um ended up doing um you know two summer
internships one of them was in
consulting at bcg but then ended up
going
uh into uh private equity uh
uh you know portfolio uh company
management
afterwards uh and have been doing that
uh ever since
thank you david and jennifer while not
an official alumni panelist you are
still
very much an important part of our
conversation today
can you tell the folks joining us a
little bit about your role and how you
support our joint and dual degree
students
absolutely um so i thank you everyone
for joining um my name is jennifer and i
am the main point of contact at the gsb
for current students that are pursuing
your joint or dual degree
so degree requirements are a little bit
different when you pursue the mba along
with another degree and i am essentially
your dedicated academic advisor to guide
you through those differences and help
you finish
on schedule excellent thank you jennifer
and thanks to our panelists
so and thank you to all the guests at
home some of the questions are already
starting to come in
i'm going to kick us off with one
question and then we're going to dive
into some of these others
so for each of our panelists you
selected very different
joint degree programs to pursue can each
of you
describe a little bit about your
decision for pursuing
that second degree and what made you
interested in the program that you did
choose
i can start but like i don't want to be
the one that predicts the order but i'll
start this time
er i i knew that i wanted to
work in education the long term so
and i have work in business uh
consulting for
three years and a half before joining
the gsb and i had started a non-profit
program in education but i had never
actually been trained in with theory
pedagogy
all the knowledge that you're required
to really work in education
so what really guided my decision was
that my long-term goal
was inspired by the idea that i wanted
to be in the education field
and i needed the knowledge the technical
knowledge
so that was the the main idea that i
wanted to complement that but like
uh i this is not the question but like
there is a
personal story behind why i wanted to do
education so i'll give you a brief
my mother doesn't know how to read and
write i
was able to go to college and pursue
many many
goals and that really always stayed in
my mind
and i thought that i needed to do
something to the work for the world and
that's why
i wanted to want to work working
education and i currently
am doing that supporting teachers in
mexico
and i love it but that was the idea so
like the
the passion that i have for education
and the technical need
that i had for to work in the field
fantastic um i'm happy to go next
although we don't know again as long as
we don't always have the heat of this
order so
um i was pretty dead set on doing
some kind of joint mba program having
come from management consulting i
actually
i did that for two years actually felt
like you did actually give me a pretty
good sort of broad-based business skill
set i knew there were certain areas
where i want to go deeper i wanted to
i had a notion that i might want explore
investing so i wanted to explore that
through business school and i also
wanted a bit of the soft skills
development
but i also was really interested in
having a career doing something around
how
tackling environmental and climate
challenges through the private sector
and so i was really interested in mba
programs that had that and stanford is
one of the few and um and has a really
terrific offering so
um it was actually really important to
me to to do something like eiffer and i
think
a sort of similar answer to wands just
transposed to the climate arena
i really wanted a place where the super
interdisciplinary stanford we talked a
lot about like
across the street courses was so
important to me to have that flexibility
i spent a lot of time across the street
actually really
loved having that flexibility and
stanford has so many different schools
and you can really sort of mix and match
and hyper in particular
climate is a really interdisciplinary
challenge that requires policy and
understanding of other ecosystem
benefits and and energy and
like food systems that there's a bunch
there and i actually
used my april program to take a few
courses in each thing
while also acquiring a little bit more
sort of technical and engineering depth
so just like name things it took like a
land use an agriculture course like
battery chemistry so
things that really informed my ability
to be an investor in the space
after the program um i think the other
thing is worth mentioning
is the hyper program it has folks who
are also um jd's
in in the program and i think phd's as
well but there's a really great mba
cohort i
i'm not sure what the current cohort
size is but like mine was like 25 to 30.
it um you are super integrated your
overall mba class but
that cohort like winds up being this
really great network for you as you all
sort of move through your careers and
the iper
alumni base is quite incredible as well
so
it's a nice little sub network within
your broader business school network of
people who are exploring
sort of the environmental business
trajectory but taking their own sort of
angles to it
yeah and for me personally i knew i
wanted to do an mba because
i didn't have those hard skills that the
people in eye banking and consulting had
and
you know i felt like i wanted to really
get those hard skills but also
get onto a career path uh where i could
try out something like consulting
and gsb the nba was perfect for that and
more
but longer term that was sort of my
short term you know first few years goal
longer term i knew i wanted a career
that intersected with
a non-profit or public sector
and you know something i didn't expect
um
you know was that cohort you get you
know those of us that went we're going
back and forth
from uh boston to palo alto and you do
get this incredible community of people
um who are very passionate about similar
things as you
uh which you can already find within you
know any gsb cohort
but it's extra time with them and extra
you know a little bit of extra bonding
because you have that shared experience
and that extra year together
and that's something that was really
important to me and it's that still is
you know one of my primary groups of
friends that i keep in touch with
even now great thank you david uh this
next question is for
jennifer from sky wondering
what are the trade-offs between doing a
dual and joint degree or a singular
singular degree for example do you have
less choices in the business electives
that you take
so i know we have a little information
on our website but knowing
all the benefits and we'll continue to
hear about the benefits of the the joint
dual degree programs today can you also
describe what some of the trade-offs are
sure and i actually talk about benefits
and trade-offs
all the time with students but you know
i will not talk about benefits now
because i think the students can talk
about that sorry the alum
um i would say the trade-offs for
pursuing a joint or dual degree
is going to be time when you pursue an
additional degree from an mba it means
you're
doing an entire additional set of
requirements so you're going to have
less time
to take extra classes especially if
you're trying to finish
in the shortest amount of time as
possible so the train ops are going to
be
very much about time a student doing a
single
mba might be able to join four or five
clubs and as a joint student you might
need to focus on one or two
um and same goes for electives a lot of
students might be able to
go a little bit somewhat random with
electives that they choose outside the
gsb
but a joint degree student all of those
non-gsb electives are for the most part
going to be for that second degree so a
lot of it really comes down to time
and prioritizing what is going to be the
most important thing to you as you go
through this educational experience and
making decisions based on that
thanks jennifer speaking of time jesse
had a question for
our panelists how did you manage your
time so when you were
juggling and balancing multiple degrees
can you talk a little bit about
how you prioritized the things that were
important to you
during your time in the program uh and
uh you know maybe we'll start with you
we'll mix up the order a little bit um
sure happy too
well it's it's a great question so um
i like personally so i actually came in
not to be overly structured
about this but like i did come into the
gsp with like a set of hypotheses right
like a few things i wanted to test out i
was like do you want to
be an operator at a company do i want to
try investing and like
if i want to go into climate do i want
to do like energy mobility or buildings
like i had like a bunch of questions and
so i kind of
like mapped out like how i thought i
might answer each question and you you
like this
unfolded very organically in the end and
part of this is me imposing order on my
experience in retrospect
um but i think you can you you can
kind of do that to help like make sure
that you're
getting like the right mix of things
over over time so
you can say like well i don't need to do
all the clubs like maybe if i'm
you know trying to decide whether i want
to go this direction or document i can
try out one through a club and i
like figure out the other one through
coursework without you know doing
everything under the sun that seems
kind of pertinent um i will also add
that i did have the benefit of
taking two quarters um i think someone
in the chat asked about how long to do
either
um i think it's pretty commonly most the
bulk of people take
one to two quarters past the second year
that's the most normal thing
um folks actually do do it in two years
this is like relatively aggressive i
think as jennifer was saying like
you will have i think if you do it in
two the whole thing two years completely
feasible you will have to trade off
extracurriculars or something if you do
it if you add one to two more quarters i
think you
actually make no trade-offs like you can
have a very comfy
sort of comfy two years with lots of
like extra time in in the third year
and you can even stretch to three
quarters which might be if you're
like working on your company concept and
you can like take advantage of like
all the other resources that stanford
has to help you build that concept so
um so anyways that's my my two cents on
on
the timing thing i actually faced the
pressure less because i did take those
two quarters and and
purposefully wanted to stay on campus a
little bit longer
yeah and i'll say for me one of the
great privileges of adding another year
and doing
another year at hks is you actually have
way more time
you get to i spent my first year at hks
and got to
do exactly what ida was saying is test
out things you know
impact investing is that something i
want to do with my career i
you know helped run a conference on it
learned a lot about it decided it wasn't
for me
uh moved on to something else and was
able to test a lot of that
even before i arrived on gsb campus and
you get two different summers to test
test some things out i worked
for a governor's office uh colorado for
one summer
got that public sector itch i'd always
wanted to try out state government
and then i got to do management
consulting something else i'd always
wanted to try out
and so you do get a little less time
at each school but overall in terms of
your
you know overall personal development it
is a little comfier and you get a little
more time to do that development
which was super nice
my case i i got to do both in two years
i think the education degree is more
feasible because actually
the education degree by itself is one
year so
i noticed that on actually for me they
don't there were not many trade-offs
because many of the education
requirements can be
fulfilled by classes at the business
school
and maybe i didn't consider them
trade-offs because i was so
interested in education that even if i
didn't do the dual degree i was probably
gonna take
those kind of classes at the gsb so
uh that really helped me is something
that really helped me was my personal
check all the time my what matters the
most to me
essay was kind of my bible for the gsb
it was related to education and any time
i wanted to
to question myself if i was doing
sacrificing something i went back to
that essay
and say am i aligning to with what
matters the most to me or not
and if the answer was yes i needed to do
that thing if the answer was no
i i didn't do it and i prepare you like
the gsb
has so many resources that i think no
matter if even just do one degree you
always feel that you're gonna
be leaving something behind so
i'm just a data point but something that
really helped me was having
those clear like similar to ida what are
the things that i want to test out while
i'm at the gsb
and that is going to guide you through
throughout the two years so two and a
half you
if you decide to do a dual degree
thank you so david i'm going to turn the
next question over to you but i'm going
to also
broaden it a little bit uh just as a
point of information for everyone on the
call
so david pursued the mba with stanford
and
the degree at hks we do also have some
additional joint study opportunities
with the
princeton school uh of jennifer what's
what's the latest name is it the
international affairs program these days
public policy and international affairs
at princeton school of public and
international affairs
that one uh and also the johns hopkins
school uh of public affairs and intern
help me out again advanced international
studies
so we do have a couple of other joint
studies where you can be pursuing
opportunities
at stanford and with some uh public
policy programs
on the east coast and i'm seeing a lot
of questions in the q a no surprise
about the logistics of doing that so
actually two-part question
one for jennifer and then one for david
so jennifer i know that
students who are pursuing these paths
actually have a couple of options in
terms of where to start their studies
david referenced that earlier so you can
choose between starting at one or the
other
so could you talk a little bit about how
that works and then the question for
david is how did you personally manage
the logistics of relocating your studies
across the country
a couple of times
first so uh the public policy options
are largely uh there's a public policy
program
at stanford which is a joint degree and
there's also the
harvard kennedy school johns hopkins and
princeton options
for the external programs you can choose
to either start at the other institution
or start at the gsb
um a lot of those decisions can be
personal
for hks it's attached to if you're doing
the master of public policy versus the
master of policy analysis
because it has to do with the curriculum
at hks so there are some
i guess limitations if you're interested
specifically in the mpp and
in terms of what order you pursue your
studies
but generally speaking you do move back
and forth across the country a couple of
times to pursue these dual
study options and you know as i said the
the reasons for
starting at one versus the other can be
varied some students
apply to hks while they are in their mba
one year and some students apply
to the gsb when they are starting when
they're in their first year at hks so
some of it can be
circumstantial as well but that answered
the question
yes thank you yeah and i think people
have great experiences doing either
uh sort of depends on when you apply and
when you get in and what your options
are
um i i would say generally thinking
about
what type of job you want to do
afterwards if you want to do a
business-like job afterwards like
consulting
generally it's easier to finish at
business school
if you wanted to do a public sector
thing then it's
generally easier to finish at hks
you can do it either way but it's a
little bit easier if you're trying
trying to do that
great thank you i'm going to take one
question real quick somebody was asking
if you applied to both programs the mba
in another program
are you automatically enrolled in both
or do you still get to decide if you
want to pursue one
and not the other and the answer is yes
so
within our mba application there are
three programs here at stanford that you
can use the mba application to apply
to that's the masters in education the
environment and resources degree
and at the stanford mpp all of the other
programs at stanford
will require you to apply to those other
programs separately
as well as any of the external partner
institutions as well you'd be applying
separately
and the admissions processes are
completely separate they are not
the decisions are not made together but
ultimately if you're admitted to both
you will have
the options there all right turning
things back over to our panelists
uh some folks are wondering if you found
that
the the double degree the two degrees
did ultimately help you
accomplish some of the career goals that
you had set out for yourself did you
find that the additional degree and the
resources and
academic exposure you got allowed you to
accomplish some of the goals that you
had set out for yourself
yeah well i i mean the nba clearly i
mean i there's
zero chance i could be doing what i'm
doing without the mba
right just just everything i do every
day is related to that
but the jewelry degree specifically
for many of us that do it i guess i'll
just speak to myself
there's a short term and a long term
component to how you think about your
career
and for many of us it's thinking about
well i'm only going to go back to school
once
what do i want to get out of that time
back at school i'm probably not going to
go back for another masters in another
five years
right and and so it's like you know at
some point in my career if i want to
re-engage
uh what how am i going to set myself up
to
re-enter the public sector down the road
even if that's not what i'm doing
short-term
so for myself uh you know part of my
you know career plan you know
so far is i wanted to do that later in
my career
uh have not gone back to private uh to
to the public sector or
nonprofit yet but um you know
definitely excited to do that at some
point
yeah i think for me uh a for like what
has been like really integral to my
current professional experience i like
what i absolutely have had to do april
to get my current role like hard to say
what the counterfactual is i do think
that um
i do think it differentiated me i think
like quite like lots of folks are
interested in kind of like venture
investing or impact investing
and i think like the fact that i was so
honed in on
environmental themes and then to boot
had the
hyper degree was a huge differentiator
for me in that process and
it also just gave me more time to
explore like like the space that i'm
interested in so broad
it's like all sectors and i also had to
figure out like what asset class did i
want to do like did i want to do like
timberland assets or something and
it just gave me that time to be really
thoughtful about it and to find the
right
fit um and yeah i actually i feel like i
maybe i could have gotten there just
having done jsb i think i've gone a lot
further having danny hyper
and also say i'm just much more
effective in my role having denny hyper
because
theory i for like as i mentioned earlier
like just the i think i bring a bit more
like technical depth because of the
program
and i also just met so many folks
through
these not just because i was like across
the street part of the time but actually
specifically through the gsbi program
like that community has such deep roots
across the climate investing community
and in climate tech like so many
founders of
interesting climate tech companies are
often hyper-related and so
um i think it's actually just made me
better at my job so that's kind of
kind of my answer for me
definitely jess and i will
acknowledge that i was very naive when i
first started the
education degree thinking that i knew
everything that i needed to know in
education and
but i realized that i was coming with a
very private sector perspective
so spending time with people that i have
had actually been teachers for
many years uh academics people
gave me like a perspective that you
require in education to be very critical
i mean
in and i i i don't assume this is all
the cases for business but the main
predictor of success in a business is
the profit
in education it cannot be the profit
there are many things
that surrounds a student's success so
like going to the gs
to the gsb and the education degree it
really prepared me to that
and in addition to that gave me
credibility i realized that when i
present myself
just as and for mba students in the
education sector people are like
are you trying to make money out of our
poor students especially working in a
non-profit
and i'm like no no when i mentioned that
i study education that i really care
for the learning for the success the
outcomes
i definitely gain that credibility that
is required
and even with my team like i have
realized that they come to me
actually when they know they need
research and knowledge
to prove something that we're doing like
for example just today one of my workers
like juan i mean i'm researching about
this theory of education do you have any
work that supports this and the
education degree gave me that ability
to research for for actually studies
that prove that something that you will
apply with students that have
limited resources will actually work and
you're not just implementing an idea
because it's on school
and that's it so like it definitely the
business degree gave me the managing and
leadership skills
the education degree gave me the
technical and academic knowledge
that i needed to be in education
thank you so jennifer there's a
follow-up question for the two of us
and i'm not sure i'll have an exact
answer but hopefully
some new information for everyone uh
anna is wondering
what makes up the bigger cohort those
that are applying for joint and dual
degrees
when they are first applying or those
that are applying in their first year of
the program
uh i don't actually know i suspect that
both
groups are actually pretty large i tend
to only see the ones that are applying
and then jennifer is the one who sees
them during their first year in the mba
program
so the number i don't think is
necessarily as important as
a resource that the mba program provides
for students who may not have been aware
or quite sure they wanted to do a joint
degree when they were first applying
but do become curious or more interested
as time goes on
so jennifer does do you still host some
of those information sessions
during the first year of the program and
could you speak to those
um i would say at least this year there
were probably slightly more students
that applied
in their first year of the mba program
then applied while they applied to the
mba
um a lot of this is because of what
christine just said is a lot of students
aren't aware that there are joint degree
programs when they're applying for the
mba
or they might be aware and don't know
which one is best for their
interests and their career aspirations
so that's really the biggest reason why
we get students applying in their first
year of the mba
in the fall quarter we hold information
sessions
with the graduate school of education
about the m.a
mba program we also hold information
sessions jointly
with eiper to talk about the ms and
environment resources
and then the public policy program also
holds their own information session
those are the biggest joint degree
programs we have so those are the
information sessions that we formally
hold
and any other degrees that students are
interested in exploring i usually will
meet one-on-one with students about
those just to talk about
you know what the process might be what
the timing is going to be and if it is
indeed the right fit for their interests
great thanks jennifer i know harvard
kennedy school has sometimes done
information sessions with us in the past
and i know that we
also will try to participate with the
medical school on stanford's campus to
host an information session there at
least once a year as well
all right so turning things back over to
our alumni
jacob is wondering could you quickly
talk about
and i'm sure it's not so easy to be
quick about this
what sets stanford apart uh what are
some of the most valuable skills or
resources that you gain
from your time in the program
i can answer this quickly the people i
think stanford has
the ability to uh select
the most amazing human beings that i
have met in my life
and like honestly even to this date some
of my best friends are from
stanford and this network is so intimate
and so strong anytime i have had a need
they're there to help i actually spent
14 years i
outside of mexico before returning to
work i teach for mexico
and the class my classmates and people
alumni
really welcomed me and opened the doors
and introduced me to
everybody that i needed to meet here in
mexico city and other parts of mexico so
i will say
the people definitely sets a stand for
apart
yeah i think it actually is a pretty
quick answer i think
you'll hear that from a lot of people
and that was my my answer as well
i'd also add the flexibility you're not
going to find a place
where you have more options and it's
more flexible to do what you want in
this
dual degree uh joint degree program
options
um that's that's sort of case in point
it's a lot of a lot of ways you can
create your own experience
uh at stanford and uh
all of us on this call did that and
really got creative with it and there's
even more you can do
um depending on what you want to explore
and that's that's a real
privilege that you won't find everywhere
else
yeah it's it's hard to add to that it's
it the community is
so amazing and like even a few years out
it continues to be amazing it's it's
and it's really incredible but not just
like on a professional like on a deeply
personal level it's a
really great group of people um they do
a great job picking them
and and i think what david said is also
right like just the ability to chart
your own course
but and yet to access the top of the
line of resources in whatever direction
you decide to head and like just the
fact that it like we
it's both like i think gsp is really
different to you by some of the soft
skills offerings
like touchy feely and art of
self-coaching and yet you're also
getting like top-of-the-line like stem
opportunities so i think that that
marriage is pretty unique
yeah and and the size and location and
all that plays into it i think all that
would be true no matter where stanford
was
located but um there's a very just
interactive community feeling to walking
around the campus
um last year i wasn't there so i can't
speak to that but
uh you know i think going forward it's
it's uh you know it's just a
great place to just really grow close to
people
speaking of some of the things that are
unique that you find on the stanford
campus
uh laura had some questions about the
social enterprise or social innovation
and entrepreneurship
resources on campus so i'm curious if
any of you
were active with the center for social
innovation or the center for
entrepreneurial studies or maybe
participated in some of the activities
that they sponsored that you could speak
to
i was very involved with the social
innovation club and
definitely uh they have many courses
but uh even like the regular business
courses allowed you to
apply the the ideas to a social problem
so i took a startup garage
the two quarters and you we we have many
teammates
actually trying to create ideas based on
social problems
and also the social innovation club is a
very active club
they meet frequently they bring great
speakers
and actually if you have a great idea
and you're ready to
to kick it off they have a price that i
believe i don't know if they have
increased the amount it's about
150 k usd if you want to start your
your own idea one student each year gets
it
so like there are many many resources
to to support the the social aspect
and even if you're working on profit i
also would like to share this
if you go to the gsb and if you have
loans and if you
go into the nonprofit sector the gsb
helps you pay your loans so there is no
excuse for you to say that you're not
going to the non-profit world because
you have a loan the gsb is ready to
support you and
as this there are many resources this
summer actually i did education pioneers
and since i was making less than my
classmates
the gsb gave me a stipend uh
to be able to do education pioneers so
like there are many many
resources so there is the is definitely
a place to go if you want to do social
entrepreneurship or social innovation
thank you so much does anyone have
anything else to add that was pretty
comprehensive you took full advantage
while you were here
excellent uh well maybe for ita and
david then
uh curious if you could each share a
favorite
academic experience maybe it was a
professor or a class itself or a class
project
something that you still reflect on and
remember fondly a few years out
yeah no i'm i'm happy to start so um
well i actually have three that i'll
share i'm sorry there were actually so
many things but i think they illustrate
like different
components of the experience so so and
and
you know what i'm about to say it's
going to have something to do with
climate but stanford climate ventures is
this incredible interdisciplinary cost
it's kind of
um there's like stanford startup garage
and there's a and there's a couple sort
of stanford
jsp courses that are like a startup
incubator but packaged as the course
and then there's a few variants on that
that are specific to certain like areas
of application
and so stanford climate ventures is kind
of the climate version of that but it's
taught by um
this great guy dave danielson who's
actually managing director at like bill
gates's you know multi-billion dollar
energy fund which is quite an
exceptional thing he's teaching like a
25 person class and you get to talk to
him a couple times a week
um and that was just incredible
experience he brings in just so many
industry lumiere so many interesting
people and like just the
connection like the connections that
have like engendered through that class
but also just
the experience of like working through
building a business and co-creating that
with these sort of industry experts was
was so
unique um so i was that was a favorite
one i encourage anyone who like finds a
way to gsb
to take one of these courses where i
didn't wind up becoming an entrepreneur
at least not
yet and but i like just having that
experience at stanford is is really
terrific to like meet investors and
practice pitching and
and sort of ideating on something um the
second
class my favorite of like this there's
many great sort of soft skills classes
at gsb but i loved art of self coaching
with ed batista
he actually has like a really great
website with like all these online
resources that
it's just like it's such an intensely
philosophical but also applied class
like you learn how to
just self-regulate and how to like
understand your relationships with
people and how you connect with others
and sort of problem solve on your own
but also be a guide to others and
it's just like was kind of life-changing
actually
so i loved that and then my third thing
and i also
it's like another thing i was encouraged
people to do is to do independent
studies so i did
two but you can do several and i forget
someone on this club will know how many
you can do to meet your course
requirements
i did one towards my mba and then one
also towards my uh
masters of science degree and it just is
such a good way to
um meet like work with a professor that
you admire whose work you like
and just get a lot of like one-on-one
time with them and then also have an
excuse to use that towards like some
other end so in my case like one time i
was kind of like considering a company
concept around something i just got to
work with
the professor the whole quarter on that
and talked to a bunch of interesting
people the other
example i like was interested in this
like idea around like catastrophe
insurance and it actually turned into
like a summer internship
so it's just a really great way to
further customize your experience
yeah we could spend all day talking
about cool classes at dsp
look there are some classes i think
about every single day that are the
bread and butter of what i do at my job
like accounting financial modeling i
knew
basically nothing when i came to the gsb
i didn't know anything but if you want
to manage
a business you kind of need to know that
stuff and i've been shocked at how
useful it is maybe i shouldn't be but
but it really is stuff that i use
literally every day and then there's the
soft skills things that
maybe if i don't use it every day you
know do i think about it once a week
yeah actually and that's pretty pretty
powerful you'll hear this from a lot of
people
touchy feely a phenomenal course that
isn't just about what you say in
business environments but how you say it
how you connect with
others both uh professionally but also
personally in your personal
relationships which has been i think
pretty powerful
and then there's the fun classes uh i
got to take a class
with tyra banks all about personal brand
it was incredible we did a tv segment
with tyra we did
we went shopping we did all these things
um
it took a wine class you know there's
some fun classes
that have real lessons in them again do
i think about those
every day of my job no but i do think
about them
fairly frequently because they have
really tangible things you can take away
from them
and it's also an incredible lifetime
experience as well
i don't want you to feel left out i'm
having such fun hearing these stories
are there any favorite classes or
academic experiences for you
definitely one that i have applied the
most right now is managing growing
enterprises
it's a class based just on cases of
things that you never thought that you
will be leading
like breakouts between your board and
the co-founders
or like facing the pr like a press
problem and like out of the 15 cases
that i
read there have been three to five cases
in teach for mexico already that i have
faced
and i have actually i'm a holder of my
my cases so i still have those cases and
i go back to see
what what are the best things to do and
definitely is a class that i
that i recommend i i didn't realize that
it was going to be my favorite
until i started working at pitch for
mexico and i was like oh my god
let me read that case because i'm living
through that right now
amazing so jennifer two quick questions
for you
one wondering if you have the answer to
what eda mentioned do we
know uh how many independent studies a
student can pursue during their time in
the program
yes um so it's a unit limitation you can
count
four units of independent study towards
your mba so
what that means is um you could do
one unit four times so for a year
one unit or you could do them all at
once it just depends on how in-depth
your project is going to be
as far as how long you want it to take
and then in joint degree programs
those programs also allow independent
study in
in their discipline so you could
actually do more than the four
if you're doing a joint degree thank you
jennifer
one more question for you a question
came up
uh from julia was wondering that on our
website we have a list of sort of
approved formal
joint degree programs at stanford but
she's wondering why there might be some
there and not others so we have
an electrical engineering joint degree
but we don't have one say in mechanical
engineering
so this is a good time to mention to
folks that you can actually customize
a dual degree during your time at
stanford can you speak a little bit to
that process
sure so the joint degrees that are
currently approved have
um you know they've been formally
approved by the faculty senate at
stanford
and they are on the list because those
departments and programs had
an interest in joining up with the gsb
to offer a joint degree
but as christine mentioned if you are
interested in a graduate degree that is
not on that list so something like
mechanical engineering
you are welcome to apply to that it will
be an independent application process to
that department through their own
application process
and if admitted you would be considered
a dual degree so it's a little bit
different i'm not getting into the weeds
on it right now but
um you are able to do that and it's very
much
set up individually so we would just be
talking one-on-one about um
what those requirements would be and
what they mean for your mba
great thank you jennifer well we've
covered a lot of information today and i
know we're coming up on time
but of course one of i think the
greatest values in in time with alumni
is really getting to hear about your
personal experiences so as we're
preparing to wrap up today
i would love if you could each take a
moment to reflect on maybe one of your
favorite
extracurricular activities or
experiences you had
as a student at the gsb uh that was most
memorable or uh you know meaningful
to you
for me is talk the tradition of i don't
know
if any of you know but i'll explain
quickly talk is a tradition that every
in my class it was every monday two
students from the class volunteered
to give a story and most of the times
tend to be a personal story and it's
in 30 minutes you decide what you want
to tell your classmates
and in my case i suffer of the imposter
syndrome when i got to the gsb
i always wonder why am i the one to go
there
like and so like todd gave me the space
to give people
that story or what made me unique and it
was
amazing to have uh like 200 classmates
just interested on listening who you are
and then vice versa i also went almost
every monday to hear the stories of my
classmates and you get to meet that
behind
these amazing like talented individuals
that is these uh very human stories
that that makes them like amazing like
that's what i'm saying the people at the
gsb
i'm like always like i will be in the
classroom if
like what is behind that person and tag
gave me that ability
to to hear like i probably hear over 200
attack because
even at the end of the school year they
do like
a whole day old talk story so like i
definitely recommend you
if you get to go to the gsb to go to a
talk or give a talk
um for me i think um one of the most
memorable things was
actually having a chance to co-found
this this conference called the like
stanford climate business and innovation
conference
which i started with three other
classmates um and
it was just this amazing thing you know
we've talked about people a lot but just
the process of putting the conference
together like with this cohort of
like-minded students and
and the fact that it's actually the
conference is like continued on like it
still exists and sort of gets passed
down and so
there's kind of this like lineage now
that i've like gotten to know which is
terrific
um but it was just it was it was a lot
of fun it was like you know it was both
this
like intellectual convening around you
know a topic that we all really cared
about it was also kind of a party so it
was like the best of both worlds and
and then on top of that um just like the
the ability to
meet all these new people through the
event it's actually i know i said this
earlier but
i i still talk to people who i met like
in industry through that conference like
even two weeks ago someone like
referenced something i'd done at the
conference and i was like that's like in
2018
um but that was just a really memorable
sort of project and
and challenge for us to put on and has
meant a lot
yeah i'll second talk totally
transformational experience you won't
find anything like that anywhere else
um but other extracurriculars are great
uh
uh one of the biggest ones is the gsb
show
uh which i was very involved with uh
incredible
just coming together of uh you know dsb
students to put a lot of time into a
project together which is a big musical
uh at the end of the year uh that's
newly written every year and just one of
those fun
quirky things that everyone kind of puts
their hands together and has a lot of
fun doing it
so my best friends still uh the people i
talk to still
multiple times a week uh yeah we did
that together
and then one last thing i'll say some of
the most memorable experiences were on
the international experiences either the
official ones
or the unofficial ones both are
incredible
in different ways but you know through
the sort of
official ones getting to like learn and
travel with professors and and it's just
incredible experience i went to ethiopia
and tanzania
um and that was incredible um but also
did
you know student-led one uh to india and
never been to india
uh you know they they were from there
and sort of
showed us around and a really incredible
experience
you know trip of a lifetime uh and there
are a lot of experiences like that
at the gsb well thank you all so much
for
taking the time to share your
experiences with us today we really
appreciate it
jennifer as we wrap up today do you have
any
advice as one of the advisors to our
students
for students that are thinking about
pursuing a joint
or dual degree anything for them to
maybe walk away and keep in mind as they
are
considering applying uh when it comes to
how they should focus their time
and their academics well that's a tough
question
you're making me end it oh my gosh um i
think
my best advice is be thoughtful about
this
um it's an investment in time of course
but
it's really important to to always kind
of take a step back you know why are you
applying for the mba
ask yourself the same exact question why
are you applying for the joint degree
and really really think about what that
answer is what do you want to get out of
it
what skills are you hoping to learn what
content are you hoping to learn
how will this help you in your career
path and your ultimate goals after
you're done at the gsb
um that's the kind of broadest
best advice i can offer is to really
really think about this
um is this something you really want to
do is it something you feel you need to
do
um you know joint degrees are as i said
they take they're not it's not as simple
just add on a degree
um it's an investment in time it's an
investment of your brain waves all of
that stuff
and you know i just want joint degree
students to be
very invested in in what they are
pursuing instead of feeling like oh my
gosh i'm not
done yet when am i going to be done you
don't ever want to feel that way about a
graduate program you want to be excited
about it until the very last day of the
very last class
well i couldn't think of a better way to
wrap things up
and i can certainly say that students at
stanford i think do show up for class
excited every single day about the
opportunities and experiences that they
have
so thank you again everyone for joining
us we've popped up
one last poll we'd love to hear your
thoughts on how things went today
hopefully we uh did our best to answer
your questions
and i'm just going to share my screen
will real quick uh
for one additional resource that we can
point you all to at this point in time
we'd love for you to continue to stay
engaged with stanford continue to learn
more about the program
so i'd like to direct you to
mystanford.nba
you can actually customize this page for
yourself you can take a short quiz
and we can actually keep in touch and
let you know about upcoming events and
activities that are related to the
things that you're interested in
so again a huge thank you to my
panelists it was lovely to see all of
you
it's hard to believe how many years it's
been since we've seen you on campus
jennifer thank you for your time and for
your wisdom
and thanks everyone we hope to see your
applications in the near future
thank you and have a great day